i really don't think anybody in any  shape or form should use somebody else  as a validator to who they are and if  they are that begins the process of you  knowing for yourself that you don't have  all the self-esteem needed to completely  destroy life which is great that's not  bad that's circumstance but recognizing  that you don't have it and deciding that  it might be worth fighting for and  whether that's therapy meditation  readings always first about recognizing  it everyone's just trying to find bubble  gum and tape you got to get to the core  if you're struggling because of outside  validation that is worth therapy that is  worth changing [ __ ] up it's the whole  game it's about living the lifestyle  that doesn't put you there